اثار تعليق تويتر لحسابات خمسه صحفيين على
الاقل سبب مزاعم بانهم كشفوا مكانه الوجود
الى الماسك مالك الموقع ثرى ردود فعل
منتقده من مسؤولين حكوميين ودوليين
ومؤسسات صحفيه فقد عبر ستيفاندوجاريك
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
عن قلق المنظمه البالغ اذا ما وصفه
بالتعليق التعسفي لحسابات عدد من الصحفيين
على تويتر وقالت ان الخطوات تشكل سابقه
خطيره
على تويتر لا ينبغي اسكاته اصواته وسائل
الاعلام على منصه تدعي انها مساحه لحريه
التعبير من وجهه نظرنا تشكل هذه الخطوه
سابقه خطيره في وقتنا يواجه فيه الصحفيون
في جميع انحاء العالم الرقابه والتهديدات
الجسديه وحتى اسوا من ذلك ومازلنا على
اتصال مع مسؤوليه تويتر
من جهتها قالت المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان حضر
بعض المنصات على الانترنت كات تويتر
لحسابات مستخدمينها او ايقافها دون
اخطارهم بالاسباب او اعطائهم حق التظلم
امر غير مقبول وان ذلك سيصبح امرا يستحق
العقاب عندما تدخل اللائحه الاوروبيه
للخدمات الرقميه حيز التنفيذ مطلع العام
المقبل
ان يتم تطبيق التشريعات الاوروبيه
لضمان حريه المعلومات وحريه الراي وكذلك
حقوق المستخدمين من خلال الشروط استخدام
واضحه وشفافه وعندما يتم اتخاذه اجراء ضد
مستخدم فبناء على هذه اللائحه يجب ان يكون
اجراء متوازنا دون تمييز ولا يمكن تقييد
حساباتهم او ايقافها دون اسباب اعطائهم حق
التظلم ضد هذه القرارات
وفي ردود الفعل المهدده ايضا قال وزير
الصناعه الفرنسي رولان ديسكور انه سيعلقون
نشاطه على تويتر بعد قرار ماسك كما حذرت
وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه موقع تويتر من
ان تحركات التي تهدد حريه الصحافه لا
تروقها بدورها دعت رئيسه لجنه حمايه
الصحفيين ودي جين سبورت موقع تويتر
اوقفت دون سابق انذار على الفور وحثته على
الالتزام الصريحي بالممارسات التي تدافع
عن وسائل الاعلام حره ومستقله
وكان موقع تويتر قد علق حساباتي سته
صحفيين يعملون في شبكه سي ان ان وصحفي
وصحيفتين يور تايمز و واشنطن بوست ووسائل
اعلام اخرى
وقالت صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان معظم الحسابات
تناول خبر تجميد حساب مستخدم بسبب تتبعه
مسار الطائره الخاصه بمالك تويتر الى ماسك
باستخدام معلومات متاحه للجمهور من جهه
قال ماسك ان القواعد الخاصه بالمنصه يجب
ان تنطبق على الجميع بما فيهم الصحفيون
مشيره مشيرا الى ان نشر مكان وجوده يعرضه
للخطر وهو ما يمثل انتهاكا مباشره
لشروط خدمه تويتر